I have a voicemail today, which you can. Leave
me any time at two one nine two David Pakman.
This is we talked about enlightened,
enlightened right wingers who believe that
they are enlightened. Here's a right winger who
believes that he has a balanced view of the riots
and of the election being stolen in all of this
stuff. Let's take a listen. This is interesting.
You know, hold on. Yeah, hi, this message is
for David. I'm sitting here watching your show
today and you're talking about this poor old
lady, about her beliefs and whether the election
was stolen or not. Yeah, why don't you just be
honest about it instead of instead of being so
patronizing towards people? You know, what we saw
that night was. Water mains breaking in Georgia,
so the water main Georgia
story has been cited often,
there doesn't appear to be anything
odd about it. And remember,
the election didn't come down to Georgia.
So you've got to take it piece by piece.
They had to stop counting.
People were being kicked out,
so they had to stop counting. Different states
have different rules about counting hours. They
were predetermined people being kicked out,
people who had no, you can't just go and tour,
you know, like it's like it's a you know, a local
park, places where votes are being counted. There
are actual observers. But the people that showed
up in Michigan for they had no right to be there.
You know, as far as we knew,
at 130 was 80 percent to win.
That is not so. That's not true.
But more importantly, for months
we knew about the red meraj. Early votes in
person would go Trump. Later votes would go
it. We knew that ahead of time. And then they
act like it's some big shock when it happens,
you know, and everybody wakes up in
the morning and sees it completely.
So that's the you know, this person believes
they're a critical thinker, but that's just the
story Trump told. And this guy fell for it.
Thirty four o'clock in the morning and the
and the silence of the night,
you know, that's again,
you know, the idea of massive dumps
of ballots in the middle of the night.
And so. Look, it's not that people
believe in Donald Trump about anything,
really, because you seem to have basically
repeated Trump's ideas verbatim in this voicemail,
were believing I.
So, yeah, so anyway, that's
that's a balanced, rational Trump supporter who
just repeated all the same stuff Trump has been
saying for five months at this point, we've
got a great bonus show for you today. We will
talk about the progressive movement demanding that
Justice Breyer retire. We will talk about Prager,
whose latest target, kindergarten. And we will
talk about New Zealand passing miscarriage,
bereavement leave law. Very interesting. All of
those stories and more on today's bonus show.
Get instant access to the bonus show by
becoming a member at Join Pakman dot com.